amigo
see
oh
gay proposed proposed Isabelle after a
vulnerable chat with her dad we'll get
into the highlights plus my mood goes at
it with Nicole's new friend who is not a
fan of Egyptian men who try to control
their women don't you trust her one
second she know I'm just here you won't
see anybody but she didn't go it's like
one second
oh sorry he's really a sweetheart he
really is
she sounds like she's telling someone
about her dog
I'm sorry
nearly as we already really is and her
friend is looking like uh I don't
believe you
calm down boy calm down let's get into
it
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicious okay
this recap is going to be a little bit
shorter than usual because of the
holiday weekend by the way I hope you
had a wonderful Easter to those who
celebrate all right kicking things off
with Gabe and Isabelle Gabe recently
came out as trans to Isabel's parents
and at the top of this episode
Isabelle's dad spends some alone time
with him to get more clarity on his
transitions
compelos
Elementary
Persona
um
Gabe explains that when he was
identifying as a woman he didn't want to
be alive and now that he's transitioned
he no longer has those feelings he even
showed Isabelle's dad some pictures of
when he identified as a girl I made a
photo album for you just now
I don't want to see them because I hate
how I look it makes me despise myself
those are some strong words Isabelle's
dad takes a look at the photos and I can
only imagine what was going through his
mind
is
he seemingly suggests that Gabe should
make peace with his past in order to
move forward in a positive direction
[Music]
decision
is
[Music]
a good man Isabel's dad is impressive
opportunities
shortly after this moment Gabe felt
confident enough to ask Isabelle's dad
for her hand in marriage
that yes surprised me but it just proves
the power of authenticity when you are
honest about who you are with people all
sides there's a sense of trust that is
built and respect
and I know gay Bills free
I know he does to have secrets when
you're growing close to someone it's not
a good feeling but to be able to express
what you're hiding and still be accepted
and loved if not more accepted and loved
it's a beautiful thing
fast forward Gabe takes Isabelle to the
pottery spot the same place her kids
gave him permission to marry her once he
shows off the kiddos works of art he
shows her the plate he made us
foreign
area
okay let's get to the point Isabelle
amigo
[Music]
he is perfect
oh they're so cute congrats to those two
when I spoke today back in February he
told me that if it wasn't for being on
the show he doesn't think he would have
had the courage to tell Isabel's parents
he's trans
because
we were kind of like forced in this
situation that is like you guys gotta
know each other now you know
um I don't ever think that I probably
would have
been this open to her family
um her family probably would have never
known still I think that it helped
it helped us know each other a lot more
I want to say all right like I said I'm
trying to make this thing quick let's
move on to Nicole and my mood Nicole
goes to a meditation class by herself in
Egypt and hits it off with the
instructor Naran after she tells her the
struggles she's been going through with
my mood addiction then they they like a
girl they date her and then they change
her to fit with how he was raised up but
he never accepts her the way she is you
know this is like extremely common like
maybe 90 percent of men interested men
are like that so I'm so happy to be
talking to you right now I just thought
it was the only person in the world
though they see you oh my gosh look how
she looks like she she looks like a star
and then you have to change the way you
dress up you have to change the people
you talk to
look at Nicole's face
they have to make sure that everything
is under control
it is controlling isn't it but I always
tell you I love you next video and I'm
doing this to protect you oh my mood is
in trouble
noran also gives Nicole more information
about the lay of the land and Cairo
apparently where Nicole lives with my
mood is more conservative but there is
another side where women are more afraid
to be themselves we go to bars we can
drink we can dance we can have exactly
the same Life of an American in Egypt
and still be a Muslim fast forward to
later on in the episode Nicole takes my
mood to meet her new friend who he is
already skeptical about because Nicole
shared with him the conversation they
had and he wants to know who this woman
is I have a lot of foreign friends here
living in this country but they never
told me you need to meet my husband
first this is a bit weird Mahmoud brings
up the fact that Egyptian men like to
know everything their wife does that's
when Iran questions if Mahmoud trusts
Nicole and things get a little heated
don't you trust her it's not about trust
don't so don't choose that oh you don't
trust you one second
you don't see anybody
one second Mamu said she know what's up
and Iran is looking like this is what
you deal with I'm sorry these really
sweet art he really is
my impression about Mahmoud is this very
stereotypical the typical Egyptian man
only knows the people around him how
they act like and he feels safe in this
Zone and he feels that there's a threat
outside of this Zone
because he doesn't know anything else a
part of me feels for my mood because you
can tell he genuinely thinks he's doing
what's right and like niron mentioned he
doesn't seem like the type to question
rules that were taught to him it's all
he knows and questioning all you know
can be scary so if living within certain
confinements makes him happy cool some
people operate best like that but I
think it's also important for my mood to
keep in mind that just because something
works for him doesn't mean it's the
right answer for everyone alright moving
on Naran Ask My Mood if Nicole could
come to her yoga classes even though men
are there and he says no because he
doesn't want men staring at Nicole while
she's stretching we told you the man in
the class will be caring to look at
Nicole he's coming there to practice
he's not coming to church
around me I will oh watch
so now you're blaming the wrongdoings of
men on Nicole or on women so because men
are looking and staring and fantasizing
then women should accommodate to that
our relationship is Haram my wife does
that around evil
did it was it mention a Quran oh you
should know where this is about to go
Mahmoud and Iran start going back and
forth about their religion you have a
seemingly fixed minded person and an
open-minded person trying to convince
each other of what the truth is from my
experience it's an argument no one wins
you just walk away feeling drained
goddess was clear he said men have like
don't look to woman and the woman have
to cover her body oh I'm covered
or do I have to cover every part of skin
yes this was clear oh that's not clear
can you please tell me a verse in the
Quran that says this I can't show you uh
oh back check I can show you I love my
religion but there is nothing in the
Quran that says that women should cover
everything
no and there isn't any person that says
that she has to wear the veal nothing
it only says that it has to be modest do
you agree that God is fair of course do
you think God wants women to suffer and
to sweat and do you know that covering
the hair is very unhealthy for the hair
you know that the hair needs sun and air
hmm I never thought about that Mahmoud
looks like he is over it and Iran makes
it clear that she's not about following
rules that don't make sense to her as
our back and forth continues my mood
ends up putting his foot in his mouth
with this one point he attempts to make
why can't men be educated enough not to
harass women and not to look at them
of course if like I see a woman lives
like oh I want to see oh six legs oh you
know like it turns it turns on some
girls by the way never never how what's
he gonna tell me what I get turned on by
nice quads and hamstrings on a man is
very attractive in my opinion he's
thinking about how people would look at
his legs I can't ask a hundred women now
if she seems like my legs like that what
they think what is that like nothing but
your legs aren't the only legs that
exist my mood and your way of thinking
is not Universal oh
my legs like that what do you think what
is that like nothing but if like woman
leg oh so my mood is basically saying
that he would be attracted to every
woman's legs that he sees oh
that's a wrong perception no when a God
created us why didn't create we are all
have pops
this is the moment I was talking about
this is a moment where he put his foot
in his mouth
but don't worry meditation instructor
niran meditated this morning and she is
clear and on point and she checks my
mood and that comment he made when a god
creates us why didn't create we are all
hot folks because we need to feed the
babies this is a biological differences
you think the boobs are there just to
turn guys on not they didn't say that
well what was the point of you bringing
that up my mood what were you trying to
say you were talking about how women's
legs get sexualized women and men like
they have different everything is
different yes God made us physically
different but at the core we were all
made equal and ideally we should be
treated as such at least that's what I
believe for some reason equality is hard
for our egoic mind to wrap its head
around it always tries to make someone
Superior and someone inferior to feel
safe but
that's another conversation when it
comes to neuron in my mood's takeaways
of each other Mahmoud says Naran is the
worst girl he's ever met
in regards to their religion he says
that she likes to follow rules that work
for her and dismiss the ones that don't
and he feels like he can't trust her on
the other hand Naran says Mahmoud is a
follower who never dug into his religion
to see if things make sense or not they
had an interesting little back and forth
sometimes during conversations like that
you just have to woosa and remember that
we are all here learning and just trying
to do our best honestly neuron in my
mood did well this could have been way
worse people don't play about their
faith alright next week it looks like
Debbie is meeting usama's family for the
first time I don't feel so good I told
you it's okay Osama and I have just
arrived in chemistet and we're gonna
stay with his family for a few days just
put a bag over in my head okay you know
that age difference thing it's like
who's in a hurry to meet Mom and Dad not
me
hi
Debbie is so sweet all right 90 day fans
fam make sure you stick with ET because
we are covering it all I will see you
next time
foreign